everybody welcome to stream Coco we're
so excited to have back the great laura
bailey
voice-over actress and a beautiful
person extraordinaire and with us always
both Morosky the chat room Jason
O'Malley and creeper in the corner and
Rikki Wyatt just sitting over there in a
director's chair
that's right creepy that's right welcome
today we're playing a little sunset your
overdrive a game you are in yeah that's
exciting can you do can you do a quick a
quick little voice cuz you did it you
did a bunch of voices for this well I
did my main voice was Wendy the bard oh
my goodness I I played this game for
five minutes so I don't know where I
play her and she kind of it's like this
town of LARPers oh my god amazing so
wendy is somebody that is regretting
leah larper and so she takes over all
the bitter larper is a role I'm so glad
God finally brought to the screen
everybody fifth dream today can you exit
exhibit that's not real that's not
exhibit that's x.z bit Slayer Darth good
to see you what's up
alright we're gonna play this and I play
this for only five minutes and I got
murdered so I figured we trade off dad
is that okay do you want to start or do
you want me the close of the best part
and the best part of the game of my life
like yeah by the way so electric boner
Brian copling er sent this shirt last
week if you were watching
we played Uncharted I was explaining to
learn when she showed up because when
our guest shows up and you're wearing an
electric boner sure you have to explain
yourself and so so yeah she by the way
music in this game is dead yeah so sorry
Nathan Drake always has his flashlight
at waist level and it just looks like a
looks like a electric boner it looks
like a light saber light saber jump you
don't have to explain it I do I do I
feel bad I feel bad you're a guest in
our house and I'm dressed up like an
idiot exactly
Oh er says this is Tony Hawk meets
fallout really is that you I mean
apocalyptic only like crazy zany colors
oh I love it I feel like it's kind of is
like Saints Row II all right I have to
say are you playing any fallout you are
wearing sweat pants underneath your
jeans
you just put our jeans over here exactly
alert Bailey is in such great games as
Mad Max Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom
pain that's an infamous oh world
I says intimates world of warcraft
warlords of draenor you're in halo 5
guardians yes as Olympia Spartan a
Spartan Olympia Vale exactly your
chun-li and at Street Fighter 5 and 4 oh
my god amazing amazing can you get us a
quick chun-li like like the huh like to
think yes that's awesome oh my god
dream come true dream bucket-list cross
it off I actually talked to chun-li
amazing oh yeah that's right Ted and
tales from the borderlands i almost
thought we should play it's a lot of
talking it's so much talking and there's
already talking going on here exactly
and not that Bette knows not to talk
that's right just by the way to pull my
strings and tell me what to do
exactly I love it Oh Lex mm Riley says I
love her more now there we go see you
got to get you're making new fans
locally also you have an amazing your
husband Travis an amazing web series
critical role on Kika shrubbery every
Thursday oh I would love to I spent my
entire high school playing D&D I told
you that we used to have a special room
at Denny's reserved for us
yes as Denny's every Friday night that's
right we were the hours hours like five
six hours at a clip Denny's was 24 hours
so we would play
you can't play all of it I would have
multiple grand slams in one night yeah
it was just like I was kind of the Babe
Ruth of Denny's in a weird way in a very
sad way exactly is in the house into the
house we tell us about your character
for critical role oh well I'm I'm a half
elven Ranger okay name vex all yeah vex
all yeah no how did you come up with
your name I just thought it sounded cool
it does sound cool that's great elven
name so it has to have an apostrophe in
it okay extra extra twin brother in the
game so we made our names vex and bags
and then we're like it needs to be
longer in elevation yeah mine's max
Tavia and your vex field on a backside
what would sit what's it what backfield
on VAX your guard yes it sounds
amazingly of it oh boy these guys have
really bad eczema what about if these
guys are just misunderstood and they
just need cream for the rashes they're
all hyped up on that like campy juice
the weird Mountain Dew II crazy Oh Marta
Ford says man oh so happy time actually
Johnson back in the last episode of
critical role hope she shows up again
this Thursday Ashley Johnson is in our
game yes and she's been filming blind
spot that's great um in New York but she
Skyped in for the last time she's Skyped
in dude it was so wonderful we have a
question how do people come in and out
so quickly of a D&D game well she's been
in our games
she's been here yeah she's better game
for like three years but our Dungeon
Master Matt Mercer mm-hmm I'm hearing
all I'm doing is how you met Danny no
wait please
our gunga master is amazing uh-huh wait
what he's but naumann what makes him
amazing he's so fast
he's like the quickest guy I don't know
how his brain works that fast like last
Hilary Ashley found out like ten minutes
before the game that should be able to
join us okay and he's like oh let me
okay and then in ten minutes she was
like he made her come into the game and
it worked perfectly you could say he
rolled with it thank you thank you
sorry sorry I'm too busy mugging the
camera like an a like a terrible
electric boner oh man what am I supposed
to do here you wait you said you beat
this game yeah so wait what am i this
also why did somebody just paint a shoe
on a wall look at how long that footage
those laces are like 20 feet long that's
crazy-looking yeah and then WHAM I know
that's look you know I my murse is not
the only guy whose brain moves fast mine
is full of Diet Coke and nerds I eat a
lot of nerds please I apologize for the
sweat by the way you don't have to touch
the ground ever oh my god that's right
wait so this guy's got like soap shoes
on her so have you ever heard of soap
shoes some shoes of these shoes so I'm
like a big kid right obviously says the
electric boner man and so shoes are
these shoes where like here I'm not
showing this correctly so like it's a
shoe but then this part is hard plastic
so then you could actually grind on
stuff yeah you can like run up and then
like grind up this yeah super cool I
didn't I I I jumped onto a rope because
my friend Tom crow who sells like had a
skateboarding stuff give me a pair and I
jumped onto a pole and immediately
slipped sideways and not who I had to
get the ball like immediately it was
like it was like the cosmos saying you
should take these off immediately the
your you're not ready for this no I mean
I got look this thing this thing don't
work so well anyway on the best of days
yeah wait so how did you do that you
press X press X are perfectly grind and
to jump on things all right this is
great you're teaching me fundamental oh
great you know there's nothing more I
like better than tutorials right oh wait
there's every I like everything better
here we go what are we doing - deli
- back with dad said he's gonna get you
gaming loves play gaming gloves wait do
they make those wait guys million dollar
idea terrycloth gaming yeah oh yeah it's
like that crook or like a caste or
somehow passed in my head yeah okay I'll
be open weapon wheel great high fidelity
got it I think is crazy
so wait you're playing Fallout now what
does shim your what are some should you
have do you love RPGs generally are
there any of G's that you haven't played
that you want to you're in Dragon Age
yeah Inquisition which is pretty awesome
which is that's like my favorite RPG
ever is it hard for you to play games in
you're in well no okay I mean sometimes
it depends on the project but um
perfect but like Dragon Age I'm not like
a huge huge characters or anything so I
show up throughout the game okay cool it
was good I just I made it myself
that's awesome myself okay I tried to I
always make you know my friend Willy
always plays characters who look
completely different from them but I
always try to make myself in-game the
problem is yeah I agree
but the problem is you know I just I do
my best the character creation but like
it fallout 4 I just look like Anderson
Cooper yeah I like and then I put some
scars in my face and I was like I know I
just like Anderson Cooper got attacked
by a cat it's just like it's not a good
look for me I just I wasn't happy with
the way she looked and then I kept
seeing people like putting their people
on line and they look totally hot right
like why does mine look so stupid right
why do I look so don't feel I last night
spent forever I went to Diamond City and
just I'm the reason for the facial
reconstruction yeah hell yeah
like two hours redoing my face and
giving her like a better do you travel
ever make you and your husband tries
ever make characters that look like one
another and then just completely just
get killed all the time no I when you
guys are fighting like
passive-aggressively like play as a girl
okay okay I'm in an RPG I'm gonna spend
that much time on it I want to be a
chick I feel yeah nobody wants to be
dudes in our I mean I'm sure Witcher is
that's right
Ferriday say such a what is such a
wonderfully filthy mouth is president in
Saints Row
I love it no way to say we talked about
this very briefly before we started but
how are you inspired and I don't know
this is true is on your Wikipedia page
how are you inspired to get into acting
a little show called da da da don't do
this no do you really don't want to talk
about it no it's fine I okay cuz I think
it's awesome I think it's awesome
okay yeah nobody our age watched
Dawson's Creek wink wink wink
um but I was watching this interview
with Katie Holmes and I was like okay
and in the interview she was like a
theater program in her high school that
she was efficient for this show doesn't
scream oh she got cast but then she
didn't know if she wanted to take the
part because she would have had to leave
her like high school production and left
him and alerts when they've been hurt
yet to go to a giant TV show I think
she's from Ohio she's got a good Midwest
heart that is important so I saw that
and I was like oh my god I like started
crying went to school the next day and I
was talking about here wait Jonah's ass
Laurie IV ever dressed up as a character
you voice acted and blown to everyone's
memory one's mind everyone's money the
only character I've voiced and I dressed
up as a Black Widow
oh yeah it's Romanovs yeah so every if
you're nasty
it's romanov every Halloween the cast of
Avengers dresses up as Avengers oh
that's awesome that's awesome Halloween
I was wearing the costume anyway amazing
I'll grow up they used to use it fine
character really well violinist players
maintain agency I'm not sure if ravers
talking about oh that's right well John
Cena be on the show Batman John Cena has
been on our show before he will be again
a lot of the WWE you guys have you ever
worked with any of the WWE people
they're all super cool Paige came in
here she's a diva
yeah she's great and and all the WWE
people are so nice and it's so funny
because even like the heels and the bad
guys are the nicest people ever yeah oh
my god like that like WWE people like
get it like they understand and like
Roman reigns came in and we played he's
like you know like one of the biggest
guys and we played like him in the WC he
kicked my ass actually he was pretty
good I gotta say oh yeah I mean it's a
good button masher anyway amazing yeah
as I'm dying yes you're amazing slash
sweaty and terrible in video games
exactly exactly
is this Tony Hawk dirty grab says no
this is like fallout meets Tony Hawk
only this is the I have to say I'm
pretty excited about I feel so many ooh
I have to say it's pretty I hate like
the fact I love to stow P in games but
they all are kind of the same in terms
of like the color palette awesome right
this is like exactly exactly what's
happening I think what's happening is
our splitters dying heyo mouths yeah I
think our splitters dying gotcha
well we could you know we can play on
this screen that we just play on the
screen see we gots we have multiple
screens here exactly
it's Tony Eagle amateur skater or or
crackdown meat so did you ever play
crackdown no crackdowns like Grand Theft
Auto but you're a police officer who has
like super powers so you got like throw
cars at people imagine like a crazier
grant GTA super fun super fun oh yeah
there you go so Laura tell Erin about
Laemmle and Titans grave Oh tell me
about Titans grave all right
who is this Titan and what's his grave
about so I'm under
what so after oh now you get to play and
tell me about Titans grave so we're
ready a tabletop show and what did you
got here just play on this one what did
you guys what did you guys because does
he play a different game every time I
tell tabletop yes okay Titans grave is I
know it's impossible right
it's impossible lions grave is an actual
I could play if you wanted to
Tony's game is a it's a table I'm going
like campaign so it based on one of the
book RPG like it was based on the Dragon
Age system got it okay but I play this
cyborg half robot cyborg half human
awesome badass girl named Emily now here
here's my here's my quick problem with
sidewalks I'm just gonna say it I'm just
gonna say it
it has to be said my phone screws up
every twenty minutes if it was you as a
cyborg what have you needed like a dis
you a glitch all the time look at this
splitter is killing us imagine now it's
like your arm
Oh whoops oh sorry who's ever car that
was so lonely Laemmle was your character
Emily's my character she has a robot
that's that I need you doctor lobotomy
that's the doctor is in your brain I
love it oh wow that would be great oh
man that's so fun I have to say it is
like crazy I'm glad to see like
Hollywood finally catching up with
because like at the end of the day like
Dungeons and Dragons and and tabletop
games at their heart are the best of
what Hollywood tries to do which is tell
compelling stories and engage people and
these epic battles yeah and it's so
weird that like in the 80s and 90s I
feel like it was an underground thing
because now it just makes life its
natural that it's like pop culture and
cuz it's a it's fun right a it's fun and
B that's what they're trying to do by
Spinelli's money to make movies other
shows what's crazy basically when you're
playing it's like you're a five-year-old
again you're kid playing make-believe
like yes anything you say work yes only
now you can have a sword that shoots out
your thing you can drill people
bloody do it but it's the best it's the
best can you play it can you put the
mask you put the Box in them write about
they're any games that you would like to
work on as a fan question um well I'm a
fan of all things Bioware oh yeah bye
where's awesome I did do I mean I did
Dragon Age and I did a little bit in
Mass Effect 3 but like kind of play
massive play what am I doing with my
life it's so good yeah so to be a Mass
Effect's yeah that's great yeah but also
like how here's a question because one
thing I think that might be a little
frustrating for working in video games
is it takes so long to write exactly so
it's like with Mass Effect like how long
and maybe I don't know if you remember
but how long from you like recording
those voices was it before the game came
out was that like a year it was about a
year that's insane I mean with Halo cuz
you also did mocast good Ashley did MOCA
not like a year and a half two years
before the game two years is sort of
ongoing but right you know some of the
vo we recorded like three months before
it was released right we started forever
that's crazy that's good
but I guess now you're coming now you've
done so many that maybe are you ever
used to it or does it every time you're
like man so sometimes if I'm really
excited like Courtney Taylor who you
know she found out when she was the
female player in fallout 4
uh-huh and she was I don't know how she
kept that secret for so long they did so
much recording crazy and when I finally
found out she was really like of course
yeah and now I love it I love to you
like if you had brought up because I'm
sure you talked about fallout 4 I
shouldn't say any what this fallout
fallout was it come home and tell your
friends about it pull out what is it
called
yours
uh me that's hilarious is the it seems
like your world probably you guys all
kind of know each other like right kind
of a little bit of a family which kind
of seems pretty which is actually fun
then when you're recording on something
you can yeah you can know if you know
who the actor is that you're playing off
of you can like get a better idea
do you ever get to play off of actors
live oh yeah sometimes it'll record
together that's awesome
that's great youtubers asking how long
you guys recorded halo 5 or in if Nathan
Fillion
I never met no castle so he was never we
get a couple like group recording
sessions with them with me and Cynthia
okay but he's always filming that guy's
so busy right Captain Hammer
oh so busy what are they gonna make I
want to know when they're gonna do a
sequel to the doctor horrible single
right that was amazing so that's a big
fan of that right that I do I do I do
like that I enjoyed it immensely she
says in a very calm and controlled
manner there we go now I'm talking Prius
is in the way I know my brain is broken
it's broken
I can't its doors yeah it's all the diet
coke yeah so it's just it's one part of
my brain to just separate it's like you
know what John Travolta and phenomenon
yeah you know where he gets the weird
tumor but he gets superpowers that's me
I think my bringing it yes bring yeah
well that's like what they yeah that's
uh I felt kind of bad from in that movie
but I also felt like wow well that's my
life I feel you bro so much love for
Lord of Bailey that's great but see any
love for play in the stream also I get
Diet Coke rage no love for bread in the
stream it'll happen
Chewbacca's dad says it'll happen when
he wakes up for age of Ultron I like to
see that you also react physically to
because I do that a lot in games I feel
dumb where I'm like oh oh Juke him you
know like yeah
is that just God like that's a bad
what's your gaming setup at home my
gaming setup so Travis and I have
because we can't
oh I would be able to share either two
rooms side-by-side awesome so he's got
his gave me set up in his office and
I've got my set up in my it's not really
an office I dunno business innit no you
take care of this it's my craft room do
you crash
what kind of crafts are you talking oh
wait Laura Bailey do you have an Etsy a
secret Etsy page no one knows about my
god and we're all about to know about
you're gonna tell us how you say I used
to sell jewelry really I really did what
kind of jewelry Oh like you know like
vintage pieces mixed in with like newer
really that's cool inspired by what
inspired by I was not working as an
actor I needed to burn fire-eating
heaven to eat but I mean like what kind
of door like what kind of jewelry wasn't
like what did you like what style would
go like I would go and find like vintage
pieces so I would like get like Shane
work and yeah interesting very much in
the style of your acting work I'd say
Dragon Age yeah but you stop doing that
because now Tyler works coming fast and
furious you quilt oh my god let's talk
about quilting no I gotta say it is kind
of is awesome
wait what's the last quilt you made the
last quilt I made actually see it all
comes back around you think I'm joking
about the the quilting stuff but it has
value and hired me for their second
anniversary to make a t-shirt quilt of
all these t-shirts she collected a
moment ladies oh my god what makes a
good quilt I like for a club to feel
like it's it's love
so it's like with t-shirts with like old
t-shirts that's a perfect quilt it's
like yeah now like the starchy electric
boner shirt I got on this will be soft
though one day electric slap now why did
I say hashtag electric boner goes soft
just the problem is I just set myself up
for this stuff yeah it's soft boners
soft electric boner dim electric voter
do not send me and Adam electric boner
shirt but thank you for this one oh man
idiot it's happening that's probably
gonna make it that probably made this
one under it exactly they just start
getting like that that is the best yeah
wait that tell Laura Bailey your
newsletter name the best
wait can people subscribe you don't know
- the best newsletter do you want to
give it a plug yeah exactly
hey I got a spot um have you ever
thought about cuz I feel like you have a
large audience you can really do a lot
for the world of quilting right you know
you could be a leader in the world of
quilting I don't think I'm good enough
oh stop that that's exactly what the
leader quilting would say humble humble
like seriously well more like squares
that's nothing crazy aren't quilts
supposed to be squares now are you
making you're holding yourself to a much
higher standard I think being a twelve
world when I think of a quilters where I
think of squares
I think square is put together in
blanket form that I can wrap myself up
yeah cozy cozy uh what kind of quilts
don't have squares other different but
wait here's just honestly I'm sorry this
has gotten into a quilting conversation
but this is important you need to get
ways you know let's say and this is an
honest question yeah let's say it's
circles okay Oh that'd be hard well what
else yes they're all hard except for no
like no like trap is
weeds or like oh you mean smushy squares
as I call them that's a mathematical
triangles that look really cool but you
could do that easily and like they have
this like star pattern like think about
like Southwest yeah but that's okay this
is my question let's say it's let's
let's say like the squishy squares or
parallelograms whatever we're talking
about and triangles all fit together all
the good but like a star you turn to do
a what happens if it's a shape that
doesn't naturally tesseract
thank you very much Beth and you met
smaller pieces to Hill in a little bit
it's a thing see she doesn't know a lot
about cool oh wait let's start a
quilting channel that would be amazing
that would be amazing you can be you
could be the bob ross of quilting happy
little happy little squares i got dark
very quickly beat the devil of learning
a lot about is precious and then get the
water out he would like slam it against
the little easel and go just beat the
devil oh yeah I think you had a lot of a
lot of angry little squares that's a
good nap you little squares yes I love
it we're doing it really we're doing it
no your brother's coming we're coming
along after your brilliance that's
what's happening and you know what else
is happening is this guy with the cool
hair and weird eyes that I've made by
the way I know if you could see it he's
got cool cat eye yeah he's got weird
goat eyes by the way go ties our
rectangles did you know that the pupils
no yes no yes go dyes look it up Beth
Beth Google goat Isaac what somebody I
think that's you but that's no no it's
like a because they yeah they're
panoramic vision they can almost see
behind yeah they've rectangular pupils
it's insane you know what I'm sick you
know what I'm thinking my brain who are
Bailey quilting challenge goat pupil go
pupil quilt of all go dies yeah just
your eggs actually now that we're
excited yeah actually that's like a
regular quilt so forget it but if you
call it a goat eye quilt sentence then
it's self
yeah very satanic pray satanic go die
quilt that's something you would see in
a fallout dystopian world it's like in
the dystopian world all the quilts are
just go die quilts yeah that's a very no
way have you heard of this podcast
welcome to night Vale no Oh Laura Bailey
you're gonna love this podcast it's like
it's kind of like what is it like it's
community bulletins from like a Twin
Peaks in town it's a fiction podcast but
it's like basically this guy just reads
these court these things that are
happening it's really well-written you
would absolutely welcome welcome to
night Vale and it's been going up for a
while but yeah it's kind of like like
here's an example here's an example this
guy Cecil right he's the guy who I'm
grinding back into death so it's like
you know like the kind you know of the
you know the put the board of parks and
recreation from night Vale are pleased
to announce the opening of the unite
built dog park the reopening they do
note however if you know dogs are
allowed inside the dog park you know
please do not enter the dog park if you
see hoodie pay no attention to the
shrouded hooded figures chanting in the
middle of the dog park do not go in to
the dog park it's like stuff like that
over and over but I'm playing a video
game and trying to recite an old night
okay so it's much cooler than I'm doing
oh you want to give it a shot yeah Oh
YUM I'd like how it comes in different
everything
me I don't know how to use melee on this
what are you man I see yeah Oh Ren
random slipperiness sunset overdrive is
such a grind and then David Crusoe puts
on his sunglasses there - how do we do
it free no one of the 103 says why is
errands so gray I went grey when I was
14 it's horrible on the mutants what are
we trying to do here I think we're going
towards I think we're going to it you
want to go up and right you want to go
towards the yellow X I think we're
trying to get yeah yeah I love it
yes cuz I'm old exactly exactly
oh you look like the actors who play
Super Girl oh I do I don't know I don't
know what's that actress I don't know
what I mean I guess that doesn't mean
everything all right maybe your bone
structure maybe they're just talking
about your monster yeah you have a
Kryptonian and Supergirl
she's Kryptonian right yeah exactly
she's gotta be right that's how exactly
yeah I think so that's the whole point
Morna for it being great 14 was not
quote badass but it I lived through it
that's why I'm funny right
YouTube was asking about your yeah yeah
Lucina there we go in that from Fire
Emblem are you a are you a fighting game
a fan are not very good at like my
friends actually Ashley
uncritical all yes yes yes
Wow got some moves she we all went over
to her house and played Mario Kart and
then played smash brothers that's
awesome
and it was four of us trying to play and
we just all of us I don't have you
talked about this last time but yes it's
Spartan Vale there we go there that's
right there you go that's how you play
this game thank you thank you yeah
you're seeing a true person true master
this game see that it's giving me
there we go finish dance I could have
brought my my my gaming oh I know note
of it it isn't you can do all these
really cool man I know well this is I'm
wearing bunny ears over a helmet
Oh weak should we make this guy cooler
looking maybe we should make this guy
cooler how do we do that I don't know oh
you have to get close you have to like
find a lady that you can buy clothes
from yeah I think it's a person's
actually I I love it I love it ohoo
scene is all I use in smash this tank
King tgp people I think I kind of missed
the smash thing like I was like a street
fighter guy and then kind of a world
combat guy and then I kind of miss skin
yeah Tekken right right oh my god I
played so much techy so much thank you
so much Tekken that's like in college
literally if somebody hits someone else
to the frame we knew so then you would
just die because then it was like you
could use all the tricks and like the
rhythm but no aunt bee quipped what's
happening
nice one thing that does kind of stink
about Monday melee because we're always
playing and talking is I never know
what's happening in anything I have no
idea what any of these weapons do I
don't know what to do I don't know where
we're going I have no idea this game
looks amazing I'm equipping this I have
no idea what they're doing the missions
like you can't really concentrate on
mission yeah amps are ready to go great
I have no idea what's happening I just
don't my hair looks good and this dude
is getting ready to party oh here we go
no wait you do something it's giving a
thing to a lightning bolt I don't know
what that means you're that's your
charge meter so you do combos jumping
from grinder grind or like flipping over
things yeah and you get there we go oh
wait you know what he's asking are you
done with persona 4 for good okay so in
persona 4 yes I play wheezing okay
awesome but very blask
that's a trying to go ahead but she so
in dancing all night I didn't get to
come back for it because I just found
out about it too late and I was already
no conflict for that game so I don't
know I mean I would love to come back
and do more if it comes up but I don't
know if there will be any more there we
go
so TBD there we go
exactly the love is there that's right
oh my god this guy's why I didn't think
you missed this move initially it's cool
right yeah what about monsters
they're just eatin this Turkey or you'd
be right up I'm assuming I'm assuming
that's Turkey because turkeys delicious
I mean I would be on the ground doing
this thing absolutely
let's talk Thanksgiving yeah uh now art
are you going somewhere are you hosting
what's the deal no I'm going to visit my
family perfect in Florida
nice are you do guys do a turkey what do
you do yeah
my mom cooks way too much I love it
that's awesome
my family yeah everyone comes over to
our house which is awesome and also
before applying because whoever hosts
then has leftovers and that's where the
pounds come in that's where you put on
the path Oh see that smart I'm too
selfish to do that I just say get out
and I also said halfway halfway through
dinner
stop eating my shrimp yeah you see
whatever you want you know what I don't
think this is killing anybody
well no yeah jump and bounce and then
slam down in some oh he's not what I'm
supposed to do I don't know but that
could probably work you study my high
fidelity weapon oh all right now they
tell me it's like New York like getting
on the subway you're on the gun yeah
this is comic-con let's go yeah exactly
freebies uh I want the Conan bobblehead
Jesus Christ
I love it
I know the that was really fun we we
teamed up with Funko were awesome folks
and we made a couple pilot and we're
going back next year which will be great
yeah you're good you'll be there right
dick what's what was your favorite
memory from this past Comic Con your
favor experience so many so many what's
up rushing about Dungeons & Dragons oh
that's great you're in the home of the
jocks yeah talking about the nerdiest
thing ever I love it I love it only the
only thing nerdy would be solving a
theorem like like like the pitcher's
mound yeah yeah exactly exactly it's
perfect nerds unite I love it the
Ascended nerds although I do kind of
worry there's gonna be a jock backlash
you know because look we can't sustain
this level of a nerd demand Hollywood
jocks and nerds are there are jocks
ain't there jocks were nerds and nerds
who are jobs yes yes absolutely
absolutely and it doesn't get any
nerdier than an uncritical really that
is that's amazing yes that's incredible
yeah so it's out there I think it's a
lot of people that write em and be like
I play football yes you know none of my
friends are interested in talking about
DD but because of the show yeah do you
think there's ever gonna be a time where
like it's just like jocks and nerds
don't are just totally cool and they
don't I hope that time is soon the time
is upon us I mean not for like kids
right exactly but can't you get a little
older anything kids don't know their
power like they should just team up
against the teachers they don't know you
know what I'm saying
I got the establishment yeah I guess so
yeah that's true this is very true how
it seen was it to get such a talented
cast for tales from the borderlands you
Troy Nolan Ashley etc it was all up to
you it was out you pulled the strings
you cast everyone great casting thank
you know everybody was amazing do you do
you guys like have this is actually kind
of a crazy question because one of the
fun things that in that we get to do an
entertainment have rap parties yeah do
you guys have rap perseverance or no
that's kind of cool like a launch party
I guess they're like parties right it's
like years later right I mean it depends
on how big the cast is and stuff and
like with tales in the borderlands I
feel like we totally would have
everybody get along so well but you know
they are based out of San Francisco
right so many of the studios are not in
LA and the actors come from different
places so it's so hard to get everybody
together yeah we'll get a notice saying
there's a wrap party it's in Seattle and
really great
that's true where are the big it's it's
Seattle it's San Francisco so you had so
you being in these towns alai do you
have favorite places you like to go and
hang out Seattle is do beautiful oh my
god I know it's amazing
although rainy so great which is why you
need your coffee but I feel like all the
times I've been there it's been it's
been lovely yeah I think it's normally
shy there we go that's awesome yeah you
used to play when he's a kid
great now what's this character malloc
or right I know yes or no I mean yes but
we we played with called kaldorf
Calder there we go his character in the
last weekend I never oh that's right cuz
when he came and joined us that's
awesome yeah yes that's so cool that's
all I did he he must have really had a
good time and he knows what he's talking
about cuz he used to play all the time
yeah yeah I mean he was you he knew he
knew it was doing yeah for the first
like five minutes you could tell he was
like and then by the end what was one
thing that kind of surprised you was
that your first time meeting him yeah
what what's one thing that kind of
surprised you about him that people
maybe wouldn't normally assume about him
I mean other than the fact he's played
easy yeah that he was just you know he
oh he was the token like aficionado
really Junior told ya he knew everything
about Ben wheeler
really yeah he's very surprising an
awesome by the way I love that see nerds
and jocks coming together that's right
it's already happening it's happened I
also feel like the rock is a big nerd
too
I would like
find out I would love to find out the
rock is a huge area I do follow my
Instagram he is a promotion that guy
it's also like he'll post like these
crazy videos to like he's got some farm
or something and he'll post these insane
I love I let me back up I will I love
any celebrity that has no buffer between
their social media and right because
like as a fan it's very powerful things
right like your fans like the fact that
you're on Twitter you talk to your fans
directly right is mind blowing fear vans
like and I and when I was a kid to be
able to talk to MacGyver or you know or
like Sam Beckett from from quantum leap
amazing amazing amazing
but it's actually amazing so the fact
that the Rock Hill post these crazy
videos like like there was a deer in his
yard one time and it's like a because I
started the video it's just like a deer
I'm like what the hell and it's like and
then he starts breaking towards a deer
and it's only 15 seconds I was like oh
my god this is incredible
he's a psychopath but he's he's amazing
and made me laugh so hard I it was so
great it gives me hope for uh
for the future of Hollywood yeah random
Slurpee that says Vin Diesel is just a
nerd that got buff that's true it
rattles your chest really it is so great
human subwoofers yeah that's awesome
just like yes like grass like whiskey
poured over gravel hey and one sexy
voice yeah yeah ooh top 10 sexiest
voices top 5 huh your husband not
including Travis is a very sexy voice
Clancy Brown super awesome voice hello
yeah amazing blue wait to see bloom did
what Steve bloom he's Wolverine kind of
in general oh nice
oh gee there we go I also love the fact
Clancy Brown is in Highlander and then
now has like this whole like like more
bigger career absolutely my there we go
okay don't let him get to that don't get
to the back yeah ah which they're gonna
start coming in huge like waves
bigger than this yeah guys get away from
them go down there with the crowbar I
feel like I'm definitely you're out of
ammo you're out of ammo and you're
protecting your vanishes awful this is
the one not to get that look maybe I
should jump down no don't jump down
there well what should I jump down and
slam yeah yeah yeah yeah wait how do I
do the slam down again get poppers and
maybe eggs oh wait but there's a giant
gap in the fence right here that's okay
oh now they're gonna get through oh yeah
oh look at all these things I got oh no
oh the bat protected well she doesn't
even need me that's wave so this guy is
voiced by Yuri Lowenthal going high
fidelity just throwing him out exactly
he's in Titans great with me this guy
right here really nice there we go
I gotta say this a-hole he was back
before you know what you're just
compensating for the fact that your
right to arms are wimpy looking at least
you've got some records hack him with
flame yeah that one's good Oh
it's gonna be so bad get up in the air
no no I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm
good I'm good no I'm good come on Oh Jan
the things going out oh my god the worst
I'm killed look at me I'm your son this
guy get up in the air she said hi look I
know what I'm know that was bad that was
bad
get him in there oh he's dead we did it
thank you
oh man I love whoops
we hold our do oh yeah how about a
little music you guys like Lawrence Welk
you want to hear give it a shot give me
a shot Jimmy oh my god no I put you in a
bad spot oh my god I thought that was
protecting itself it's not protecting
its own thing Oh No here we go oh no
wait best lemon cloud over your face has
no face that's a pretty good one great
job Leigh thanks smokey afford 20 oh no
get off the ground
see jeez Lord's doing it right throwing
a bunch of Kingston Trio albums it's
Peter Paul and Mary you're killing them
how did you get the super I think your
thing is doing something that's double
super I'm going that's why you're
missing out on the combo great oh oh you
get composting you grind
oh that's all you had to say that's all
you had to say I just couldn't really
have no interest in video games no he
like he hasn't interested and he's just
terrible at exactly he died you playing
video games with his son well done well
done
hauled my ass out of the fire whoo
YouTube chat question I learn any advice
for people getting into online voice
acting or acting in general well I don't
know about online voice acting
but when you were just getting started
how did you get started so like you saw
Katie Holmes is interview her like I
love it and then what he what was the
next step because I think for a lot of
people it's that gap between how I want
to do it and then how did I yeah well
when I started I didn't know I wanted to
be a voice actor okay I wouldn't be an
actor okay so I was doing theater and I
was working on camera never make that
but I was doing a play in Dallas and one
of the people that I was in the show
with was doing voices for Dragon Ball Z
oh cool and you are kid trunks
so they they asked if I would come in
and audition for Dragon Ball Z because
they come in so I did and got the part
but um everybody comes out in a
different way like a lot of the voice
actors I work with we're stand-up
comedians yeah you know all I can say is
that it's good to study acting and study
and also maybe just yeah and also it
sounds like perform also like any any
way you can like you did you did theater
and then yes some people did like
stand-up and then there's also improv
I'm sure which is a big yeah but all
those things and I think that that's
true also for comedy for us and for me
and for writers on our show is like just
getting yourself amongst other people
who are trying to do the thing you want
exactly and everybody starts
brainstorming and they find yeah you
meet people that have you know things
that you don't have connections you
don't have a and I think too it's like
it's this weird thing because I think
that from the outside it might seem like
oh well those people are competing with
me and they are kind of to a certain
extent but also I think there everyone
is trying a rising tide raises all boats
and so everyone is also trying to make
it yeah and yet and plus you'll just get
experience and all that there's nothing
good out of you know not wanting to be
nice to other people because you think
they're gonna be yeah yeah like what is
that like yeah I predict and that's
that's honestly one of the best things
about voice acting is that the community
is really nice to each other and
supportive and supportive absolutely
absolutely and and I think that it could
be like I'm from Michigan
were you from Texas that's right and and
so and Texas is similar I think in the
way like it just feels a million miles
away from Hollywood like like III
thought it would probably easier for me
to get to the moon that it would be to
get a job in showbiz but the thing is
like it's not really a mystery like you
go and start doing these things you
start performing you start getting out
there and then it's kind of like oh this
is a feeder for getting into Hollywood
like it that because the people in
Hollywood need to find talent somewhere
right you know and that's where they're
looking is like those places just doing
it I think is and you're already be ten
steps ahead of the game if you just
started doing it all right how do we I
want to change our look oh I'm tired of
this look this look is so five minutes
ago can you talk to hat jackin I think
it's just weapons though jack is just
what he's he's taking all the
good-looking clothing those pants are
gonna fit ice those pants aren't gonna
fit maybe maybe we should fill up our
ammo geez just do it exactly Deb in
public yeah I remember one of the
podcasts and Liam recorded a day after
the audition for the same part I thought
was cool that none of them affects the
friendships in that community yeah
that's extremely cool
Nicholas move I've not seen the new
daredevil show have you seen it done
Netflix yeah oh I hear it's great it's
so good here it's awesome all right so
are you excited for the Jessica Jones I
am I'm very excited Jones yeah it's
crazy
it looks David Tennant to path the bad
guy
yeah purple man yeah I gotta watch it I
just thought man there's so many shows I
have to watch Nurse Jackie I've gotta
get my nurse jackie gotta get my mom
loves nurse jackie and nurse jackie is
great blind spot
yeah blind there we go it's gotta watch
it
good things
Daredevils effing awesome absolutely
right heroes reborn I've not seen heroes
reborn
but Zachary Levi came in and did Monday
mainly with us he was super cool and
nice he is super nerdy he's got a hole
he does a whole bunch of twitching and
all that stuff which is pretty cool
should we collect some fizzy fizzy coke
cleaning machines let's do it let's do
it now
do it now exactly
dress Lord Bailey returning for Halo 6
oh my god
coming up 2020 probably they just
exactly and also if you're just joining
us we're with actors Laura Bailey and a
thousand billion games including sense
that / guide including halo 5 Guardians
pick it up as Spartan Olympia Vale Mad
Max tears for Borderlands Worlds of
Draenor the list goes on and on it some
other way chun-li your chun-li a fighter
5 a phantom pain Metal Gear Solid which
I haven't paid played that one's on my
ass about the fact I've never played
that I'm writing Dragon Age Inquisition
absolutely Skyrim oh my god Skyrim of
Skyrim love scar which is basically
fallout yes
it's like fantasy fallout yeah and
Walker Texas fear thank you guy no way
you were do you even work that was just
2001 I remember it cuz it was the first
thing I ever whoa that's crazy
wait so did you have to audition what
was your what was it I auditioned I
played Frank Stallone's daughter oh my
god Frank Stallone by the way Sylvester
Stallone's brother who looks like him
and he's like a lounge singer he's like
this really wonderful singer yes and he
did the music for I don't even ask I
know this staying alive which is the
sequel to the John Travolta yes a
favorite which is amazing by the way if
you like there was a sequel to the music
is so crazy it's amazing but anyway
sorry you played Frank Stallone's
daughter yes alright and he's like
being harassed by a mom but I'm
basically like they're just looking I
love here's what you know we obviously
did the Walker Texas Ranger lever on our
show for a long time and what's great
cuz I had I was the video researcher at
that time on the show and so I had to
watch all of those Walker Texas Rangers
I'm gonna fail this 100% 110% I can't
even get up on the truck
ah and I just have dreams about Walker
Texas Ranger and here's the thing about
Walker Texas Ranger is it's for old
people so every bad guy there's only
three kinds of bad guys it's what old
people fear it's like a weird gang right
it's a good weird gang it's like some
kind of mystical like crazy like
whatever and there's like a guy who
wants to steal your money like a rich
guy he's trying to swindle someone out
of money that's every single episode and
which your priceless daughter and do you
remember the plot of the episode I mean
other than that he was in trouble and
Walker saying did you remember the woman
that played my mom was probably like ten
years older than me she was in 20s I
think I did it when I was like 18
that's hilarious oh my god did you get
to meet Chuck Norris I did yeah I shot
all my scenes really oh my god that's on
how was she was so nice I was so sick
but we shot it and I was like you're
sick like I was I was laying down in my
trailer cuz I was just like I couldn't
breathe like nerve nerves are you
actually how it was I was I had the flu
I was super duper singing but I go I
cancel because I was like so excited
about it right exactly and he and so
during every take I was like trying not
to cough and my eyes were watering
because my god this is awful
Chuck Norris yeah the guy who from what
Bruce Lee is rubbing your back and then
they were gonna cut my lines because it
like wasn't working and I was like okay
so they were gonna cut some of my lines
and he was like no no no come on this is
like you let her keep her line so he's
like oh my god that's so nice
that's amazing
although I did a bet handspring back up
that's awesome oh my god Walker as if
Walker couldn't get any cooler
he's an ice is the best ever and Fabrice
Lee which is again is insane I got a cry
you gotta grind it got a crybaby get up
there right away I nude that hashtag
that grind like that whoa look at me
yeah this is a pretty cool feature is
running I that was how did I even do
that Pogo from present must be fun
playing video games to get paid for I
don't get paid unfortunately I never
gave up my job at Kmart I do I shower in
props Tony doesn't know I'm on the
payroll is why I was punching me he's
trying to get me to quit Laura Bailey
though play get gets paid for being in
video games even cooler what's your real
job well those are what was our quilting
Channel we're gonna make happiness
fabulous squares I'm doing it I'm gonna
do it you think I'm joking but I'm not
I'm gonna I'm gonna make another thing
called clueless quilter sports quilts
hashtag sports quilts they're like
leather yeah exactly hats exploits go
now wrong a little bump and grind magic
man says Jake Rick says question we're
having a hundred who's also an
established voice actor brought oh I
couldn't see what the rest of it was it
went away any difficulties do
interesting when you guys fight you you
to intimidate each other
now actually it can be weird if you're
an actor and you date another actor
that's true because especially if you're
both like starting out your career cuz
it gets like and tough like especially
if one person isn't getting you guys are
both success is working and the other
one is but that's it's never it never
felt like that absolutely hey if he's
working and I'm sitting on my butt
playing fallout basically researching
doing research and he's making all the
money and I can just you know exactly
did you guys how did you guys meet again
we met we met we were both extras on
perfect and so we had to sit at a table
for like eight hours without actually
talking really yeah cuz you know you
know how to talk as an extra I don't
know if you have experienced them no no
you just have to be used mouths okay
you're not allowed to make noise you're
basically as an extra not allowed to
like do anything because the world
treats you like you're in like a moving
problem but you're at your extra even if
it's not a fun experience but um yeah so
we sat at this table you don't actually
talk just look like you're deep in
conversation so get out that's crazy
which is funny because that's what most
married couples end up doing yeah so you
guys started there now you do the good
stuff they never would have allowed but
texting each other which is great
Jackie Twitter tweeting at each other
that's hilarious that's that's really
really funny that's fantastic yeah
because I've sat at tables with girls
for a long time and not talked and
nothing's happened right so it didn't
end up in marriage no didn't haven't
enough didn't end up in anything
end up in this in a restraining order
yeah when I finally did try to talk to
them exactly uh F let's say YouTube
question which voice characters were the
most challenging
that's which yeah to be the most
challenging to what were the hardest to
get into free
the most challenging it depends on which
kind of difficult we're talking about
like difficult technically let's say
difficult technically and then say
difficult emotional difficult
technically is like yeah so high yeah
well it's high and it's like this
whatever basically like you're making
your throat like really raw the whole
time we're doing turns up so it sounds
like I mean by the end of it which
sounds delicious but is very big not yet
probably not healthy to eat burger
throat hashtag burger through a bad case
the old burger - but then emotionally
emotionally I mean sure is it's not very
often in this kind of industry that you
get to do something like really
fulfilling emotionally a lot of it is
just like goofing off and like shooting
things in absolutely you know like we do
stuff like tales from the borderlands
which has so much yeah difficult as Hale
but so worth it absolutely and for
another whole thing is the whole motion
capture when you do that like you did
for helispot halo 5 guardians and that's
the whole thing because yes oh my god
there we go then that is that just
another do you feel like because you're
protective kind of as a voice actor but
do you feel exposed well you've done
other happiness and not really is it
more is it in your head like oh now now
everything's being recorded it's weird
because oh yeah a cop yeah nine 9's yeah
what was it like doing motion capture
it's weird because um
so you're in these like suits right yeah
oh yeah so the head rigs are like unlike
running oh you mean like I was doing
myself yeah you're playing my style
you're playing my style which is just
shoot everything all the time just died
yep that's my style die as much as
possible I like to sacrifice myself to
the bad guys and then make them feel
guilty later when they're slurping their
soup later they're like remember that
guy yeah you know know first like
motion-capture you rate he's like head
rigs which are like you've got these
cameras that come out of your head so
you're wearing this helmet and so if you
have like any kind of intimate scene
like like infamous second son where we
had like an actual like makeout scene
you're in with the head so it the other
actor is wearing is too and they're like
they come out of your face pretty far
and so like you're trying to do anything
intimate you can't because like it
smacks into each other and so you have
to film it once with them and then take
the head rigs off and then film it again
like and then usually you have to go in
for face cap afterwards which means you
do that so I make out in my apartment by
myself
yeah right but it's kind of like being a
teenager with head gear I guess like
trying to like woman sometimes like in
so in Resident Evil 6 yeah which by the
way just got sent to me from a fan that
you and Conan playing oh yeah that was
great
hey yeah appreciate it no problem yeah
gotcha good job that's awesome that's
awesome
so I didn't actually do the motion
capture for that I just did the facial
capture okay so another actor filmed it
off and then I had to go in separately
and match her body motion which
and then read the lines at the same time
and and it's really difficult it is
really really difficult to match
somebody else's motion with just your
face it's crazy to me that they wouldn't
just hire you to do the whole thing I
know right that's kind of weird but I
think just think they got her in there
they're like just did most everybody
else just a facial capture as well um
but I think it's just different
companies work different ways yeah
that's interesting
I'm sure it was whatever the most
cheapest way to do it was because
everybody video games are expensive I
can only imagine because it's like
you're using like super crazy technology
and having to rely upon people acting
there we go get it a mission now oh my
god you can make a quilt you can make
five quilts in the time it took me to do
one thing exactly we should just measure
our time in quilt time right for a happy
little squares channel lol bro lol
favorite favorite Dragon Ball Z sir yeah
favourite do that bro bro do you even
bro what's your favorite Dragon Ball Z
saga the cell saga which I'm not invited
dick sounds a dick
hates so Frieza though also dick yeah
but freezes like I don't know sells
cooler than Pisa yeah I don't know when
he weirdly I was really into the manga
or whatever comics and but I so I
couldn't understand anything cuz I got
it like so I went to Japan as a kid no I
didn't know Japanese yeah and so I had
no idea what was going on in like you
know he starts off as this one different
form and then it's like sucking things
into his tail like yeah and I was add to
do the pages the other way and read it
backwards and it was all confusing and
then finally when it finally came to
America I was like oh
but it's it's incredibly that it's just
so epic on such a crazy so the Japanese
are so far ahead of us in making epics
I mean just same story anything I feel
like they're gonna flip around though
and quilting is gonna become big agem
you know because now maybe you know what
though if you like watch any because
sometimes what else you do to spend
forever why don't you two videos and
going down that what I'll see you
and so I'll watch like crafting like
Japanese crafting what what kind of whoa
what's Japanese crafting about what are
they doing like everything is so
everything is so specific and pristine
like they make these little like
[Music]
tweezers doing place like little tiny
cakes that are like this big but that
sounds awesome
yeah that's where we're headed by the
way that's where our culture is gonna be
I'm not going in Dragon Balls I charge
by the way with the sword badass and
purple hair I love my trucks try
quilting in VR heck yeah well TVR would
be amazing project more oculus cool
thing i love it you should be one punch
man if you want to see epic what is that
no one knows hashtag critters hashtag
critters I said critters hashtag we're
all gonna die oh my god hashtag pop
world in this game yeah like a voice
actor for doesn't actually I think it I
think it does
just because you know a lot of times
when we're recording it'll be like okay
now we're doing in-game dialogue now
we're doing just like call-outs and you
know if you don't actually play a game
then you don't understand what call-outs
are yeah you don't know the language of
kind of what you're doing exactly just
to know like going down this list of
grenade out yeah sort of stuff
absolutely Julie do you normally like
when you're doing kind of call-out stuff
do you give that like how many options
do you normally do for a play something
like that it totally depends on the
director Oh interesting
like how many they want cuz sometimes
they'll be like too you know they're
just gonna use one of each yeah so just
give us a safety or you know options and
then other times it'll be like do 10 of
each of the columns because they'll
probably use every single one different
what some what is some lingo that
someone who's not in the voice acting
world like would know like call out is
kind of a lingo but right what does some
other lingo for someone like me you
doesn't know anything but I like what
somebody says give the can you give a
101 what's that that's a specific anime
reaction which is a breathing out and
then breathing in as like a surprise
that's a 101 can I try it yeah do it
again like I swallowed that's all that's
all so what I call swallowing a bug for
101 wow that's crazy
cuz it's used so much in reactions
that's unbelievable
that's cool yeah I'd see that's
something I would never come across in
my entire life because I don't use this
and who really reacts like that ever
right I guess I was trying to think the
last time I did a 101 in real life I
guess what I get punched by Conan well
it's more of like I that it's more of a
muscle more of a muffled sobbing lighter
yeah the 104 as I turn away from camera
sobbing oh my god wait here's like a
horribly gross thing I don't know if
I've said it on a stream before but I
need to share it just to exorcise it for
my brain we did the last close camera
when we wore these vault suits that were
like
as I saw so we just called up and we're
Coney had to come down this ladder okay
you came down this ladder only he had to
leave so I had to do it so I had to put
on his suit cuz our suits didn't match
and he had been wearing his all day
under another suit that it was tearaway
and it was like putting on like a wet
glow it was awful that's one thing you
know what to do a voice I'd like that's
a good thing I mean motion capture yeah
yeah yeah I would something like
terrible
showbiz showbizzy oh it's not all fun
and games sometimes it's getting a body
rash from your boss's body sweat all
that I should've just squeaked what I
should have done if I was smart I'm
getting helped out Oh
oh no they're gonna try to kill you too
oh well at least they'll kill those guys
first I gotta find this sandy body right
now I'm looking for a sandy bye
right back that's okay you won't be able
to hear my muffled sobs as I get
murdered I'm out of here I'm on air
yours of lip reading sessions paid huh
oh my god good lord now if you a view
and Travis ever thought of opening a
school to teach other side oh wow um no
see there we go yeah
although I don't know if they own like a
school or if they just like do like
workshops so I feel like it's it's
definitely something that's especially
with videogames being so crazy and
something that it's absolutely exploding
I know that Charlie Adler teaches a good
workshop he was the guy that played
freakin cow and chicken oh yeah I'm
awesome
he was Buster bunny and incredible Tiny
Toons and incredible just like everyone
else like the royalty yeah you look him
up and he's been in everything oh my god
come on come on dude
no we shouldn't have bullets they
shouldn't have bullets it's all fun and
games live bullets I love it okay cow
chicken miss that show darkwing duck
darkling darkwing duck
oh that's he was he was on him in there
oh my god good lord
definitely royalty the favorite
companion in fallout 4
right now I have codsworth oh do you how
I love in codsworth he's got this
flamethrower and the blade it's great
well so far I only know I only know
dogmeat and codsworth other other ones
they haven't found it there are other
ones yeah oh the guy that's the
Minuteman guy Oh preston preston garvey
yeah he's great I don't like having
companions I know I'm gonna give myself
that perk but just like let's you be a
badass without a companion the lone
wanderer perk yeah because I don't like
anybody yeah here's my thing I agree
with you and here and this is crazy
parent I know this is crazy paranoid
gaming let me just say that but in video
games like here's a good example The
Last of Us right okay
when your main enemies are clickers okay
clickers have for those who haven't
played the game clickers are a type of
zombie like it's a fungus induce zombie
where they don't have any sight they
only come here you there is madness
happening but I don't like I don't like
my flashlight being on because I feel
like even though it doesn't draw
attention to me I feel like it draws
attention to me same thing with the
Companions even though they don't draw
no but they do draw I can't do that
really yes all right that's why I don't
that's why I don't have them because I
sneak around like if you're gonna be a
tank yeah then cool yeah but if you're
like planning on being sneaky your
companions yes
exactly and that's why I play I always
play sneak I'm like stealth sniper all
that stuff Laura I don't like anybody my
best friend's companion
so Oh Billy bill farmer is great as well
I don't know who that is
yeah let's become happy yeah I don't
like companions I don't like flashlights
I don't like a lot of things video games
I know it's crazy but no I completely
agree yes part yes fartist that's why I
said last of us the clickers and last of
us the flashlights totally like it's
it's just the clickers on to you
anything no like they don't they don't
but I don't like it cuz I Felix boat
mentally I'm psyching myself out which I
don't like which is terrible as anybody
named their guns yet do you mean your
guns
oh I haven't I feel like I should
because it's fun but I never do I spend
pretty much all my time in crafting oh
nice I just I spent like three hours the
first night just scrapping sanctuary I
love you can't make a quilt in that and
fall out can you I don't think so but
you should be able to yeah Bethesda
listen up Todd Howard listen uh you know
people would do it and Harris oh my god
totally you can make a house in a bed
you should be able to make a quilt Navi
was the best companion ever okay what's
Navi from I don't know you need your
double-barrel shotgun the boomstick
well-done pizza I love that yeah we had
we had some folks from ash vs. Evil Dead
in here a few weeks ago and what are you
watching a sh t bug them all I haven't
seen a single one
I hear it's fantastic though which makes
me really happy crap jokes McGee says
quilting DLC confirmed I would love that
I would love it yeah exactly yeah
exactly
Oh guilty 343 Guilty Spark mess might be
the best companion doesn't Guilty Spark
try to kill you yeah in Halo 3 4 3
Guilty Spark doesn't he try to murder
you
exactly that was a joke about Navi yes I
have not seen DB super yet what is that
DB super
Oh Dragon Ball Z oh no I haven't seen it
Oh navvies from Ocarina of Time
I wish fallout had boughs you just
please you just want to play Skyrim just
go play Scott I know yeah it just
occurred to me I play Goliath Ranger in
my D&D game that's basically grog and
vex Laura combined that's great that's
good oh you named your time you got my
little friend that's pretty cool I gotta
say like I will say one of the things I
love about Fallout this happened to me
last night was the trouble you can get
in just rent like you'll find this
happened in Skyrim to find like a little
cave or a hole or something and then
it's like completed unbelievable I went
down the sinkhole I was going east and I
found this weird sinkhole and I've been
playing a lot of alien isolation where
you can only save at certain points so
I'm not used to just being able to save
it anyway but now I'm like all about
just saving and then just jumping into
danger so I'm like I don't know let's do
it I was streaming on Twitch and
someone's like save and then jump in I'm
like let's do it I jump in there's like
feral ghouls there's a minor situation
with oh those are dicks I get you
exactly kept the smuggler what do you
think voice actor for recording hundreds
of names is that a pain in the ass yeah
is it a pinion has to do like it is yeah
it's not a pretty ass but it's I mean
it's hard to make sure it all sounds
fresh if you're going down like a huge
list like that and how do you make it so
brain starts to break yeah do you do you
get do you get to take breaks do you
have tricks where you're just like how
did you play games or something with
yourself to try to make it more fresh
like yeah you say if your brain like
completely fried
but also they'll still the director will
also let you know and on that on that
note it's probably way worse for them
because they have to listen and keep the
fresh ears which is also hard yeah I
feel like directing is one of the
hardest things because you're using that
same energy that every actor is using
but you have to use it the entire day
right that's crazy
oh yeah I don't know you address this
yet but YouTube asks is that we're
playing a game that you're in I like it
I mean I don't if I'm like this oh the
main character it's a little weird cuz I
already know like all the spoilers I
know like we don't do how to complete
missions but if I'm like smaller parts
in it then are you jealous
are you so critical yes why don't be so
critical it's you can't help it oh
you're yourself doing something in your
leg Oh who's this garbage what oh the
worst I know I think that's it that's
true though for all creative people like
I'm definitely self-critical I know Beth
is back yourself here we go O'Malley is
a cocky sob over here yeah well like
Conan very self-critical but it's also
like that's you get better just by being
self-critical so I don't see that as a
negative I see that's a father I mean
yeah if you thought you were great kept
the smoker
it's so weird listening to this stream
and playing hearthstone is mage I could
eat just like your brain is is breaking
oh my god good lord
well I think this is a good time to stop
hey that's great oh my god
that's got to be fun oh jeez I'm gonna
pause I don't i ah Thank You Laura
Bailey for coming in and critical role
you can find out geek and sundry every
Thursday night
and what's your character's name again
vex vex and look for our quilting
Channel happy little squares coming very
soon and pick up halo 5 Guardians
because she is in
as a Spartan Olympia Vail as well as
Street Fighter 5 as chun-li and Telstra
Morais and Mad Max and Arkham Knight and
worlds of Draenor and Metal Gear Solid
Lego dimensions so many things so many
things Lord Bailey thank you so much
thank you guys for joining us and we
will see you next Monday
you